françois poulet mathis il est
journaliste et spécialiste des
institutions européennes bonjour
françois poulet mathis et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
le variant indien inquiète
on l'a vu c'est le deuxième pays et le
royaume uni le plus affecté par ce
variant pourtant aujourd'hui le
royaume-uni en tape une nouvelle étape
de son déconfinement et pas des moindres
entre autres la réouverture des bars et
des restaurants à l'intérieur est-ce
prudent selon vous c'est toute la
question c'est la question qui pose un
problème notamment pour les
épidémiologistes qui considère que les
autorités politiques
c'est vrai en angleterre mais c'est vrai
aussi en france prennent beaucoup de
risques en des confinant de manière
assez systématique alors que visiblement
le niveau de l'épidémie est encore assez
élevé mais freine d'observation par
rapport à ce variant indien d'une part
deux observations d'une part en
angleterre à un nombre important de
citoyens d'origine indienne qui peut
expliquer effectivement que les
communications étant importantes entre
les deux pays
et bien ce variant indien ait pris
autant d'importance
et puis il ya deuxième raison c'est que
les anglais ont aucune avance par
rapport à nous en matière de traçabilité
des vaccins et surtout ce qu'on appelle
le séquençage est à dire qu'ils ont une
capacité d'analysé et variant beaucoup
plus importante et dans un délai
beaucoup plus rapide que la plupart des
pays du continent
ce qui fait qu effectivement ils ont pu
détecter assez rapidement cette
explosion du variant indien raison pour
laquelle cela peut inquiéter des pays
comme la france qui effectivement n'ont
pas cette même capacité de séquençage et
qui peuvent poser effectivement un
problème et on peut considérer peut-être
que le variant indien est déjà plus
présent sur le continent qu'on ne le
soupçonne actuellement voilà une des
raisons pour lesquelles cette résurgence
du variant indien pose un véritable
problème pour la vie d'aujourd'hui
johnson a fermé en l'accès aux voyageurs
indiens c'était le 19 avril dernier
alors que le pakistan et le bangladesh
avait déjà mise en place cette
restriction beaucoup plus tôt au début
du mois est ce que l'exécutif a trop
tardé
on peut considérer effectivement qu'il a
trop tardé mais bruce johnson avait fait
de telles promesses de déconfinement il
avait tellement promis de pouvoir boire
une bonne pâte dans un pub anglais à la
bonne date
et bien c'est très difficile pour lui de
revenir en arrière mais il sait très
bien que si jamais ce variant indien
apprenait d'une importance comme april
d'importance le var et anglais vous
souvenez vous le verriez anglais qui a
qu'eux qui a déferlé sur la grande
bretagne a après déferlé sur le reste du
continent
et aujourd'hui il est majoritaire donc
c'est une vraie préoccupation
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'il veut croire
encore aux bienfaits de la vaccination
j'ajouterai quand même une autre
préoccupation c'est que le vaccin
astrazeneca n'est pas considéré comme
aussi efficace que les vaccins à arn et
donc on peut considérer effectivement
que la grande bretagne qui est
essentiellement vacciner à l'astral et
n'est qu'à est peut-être un peu plus
vulnérables varaillon indien maurice
james elle affirme que la situation
reste sous contrôle dans le même temps
il déclare que le variant risque de
perturber la levée final de toutes les
restrictions le 21 juin en angleterre
comment interpréter ces déclarations qui
montrent que la situation n'est pas
idéale alors que les étapes du
déconfinement comme celle d'aujourd'hui
est maintenu elle est battue parce que
c'est une responsabilité politique boris
johnson s'est très bien que sa
population
on a un petit peu ras-le-bol de ce
confinement qui est qui durait et la
population elle semble assez confiante
dans l'efficacité de la politique de
vaccination royaume uni et donc elle ne
tolérerait que difficilement un retour à
un confinement sévère raison pour
laquelle il a pris ce risque
c'est un risque c'est un risque il faut
savoir comment les choses vont évoluer
il faut attendre effectivement les
analyses dans les prochaines semaines et
on saura très vite si ce variant indien
est aussi préoccupant que la firme
l'organisation mondiale
santé le premier ministre britannique en
tout cas affirmé que le variant
risqueraient de perturber il a levé
finale de ces restrictions qui est prévu
donc le 21 juin là vous dites que il se
rend compte que la population en a
ras-le-bol alors finalement est ce qu'on
peut vraiment penser que le calendrier
ne sera pas maintenu
ça c'est difficile de le dire c'est bien
sûr c'est les événements c'est
l'évolution elle même du virus et
l'évolution de ces variants qui vont
permettre de savoir si johnson et puis
aussi les autres responsables européens
à leur tour auront bien fait d'eux des
confinés comme ils l'ont fait mais vous
savez entre la vie scientifique la vie
des épidémiologistes et des médecins qui
effectivement tendre est à pousser à
beaucoup plus de prudence
il ya aussi la réalité économique la
réalité psychologique est contre cette
réalité effectivement les responsables
politiques de chacun des pays doit faire
la part des choses et c'est l'exercice
c'est bien cet exercice là qui est plus
difficile merci beaucoup françois poulet
mathis merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et spécialiste des
institutions européennes merci à vous